hallo mein name ist herzlich willkommen
heute zu einem neuen
bis heute eigentlich luca ich bin heute
nicht lokal sondern es ketchum ich habe
leider meinen körper und alles nicht
dabei deswegen ein paar sekunden später
das leben nicht verarschen
hier wird schon wieder links rechts
irgendwo eingeblendet dass es so windig
alter es ist unfassbar windig gerade ihr
seht irgendwo pokémon doe eingeblendet
ich habe wieder aufgenommen ihr seht
doch schon ich habe schon drauf
aktiviert wir haben in der nähe
eigentlich ganz interessante beauftragt
muschel aufwand nicht hinhauen kämpfe
liefern slams planen wir schon sehen wir
heute am strand und ja es ist sehr
windig ich will leute gerade im urlaub
mit max es ist so will ich heute was
sturmflut deswegen liegt hier überall
herum das wasser steht bis hier vorne
peter ob sie vollkommen richtig kämpfen
[ __ ] you
ich habe auf jeden fall auch aktiviert
ihr seht schon klappt sehr gut es kommt
gar kein pokémon vielleicht schaut ihr
andere youtuber die foto spielt man mal
was sinnvolles so von wegen wir lernen
uns wo empfang
ich mache nichts wir glauben noch um und
beschädigte das nicht geht wenn
primaries es dass ihr mich so viel
bewegen uns immer weiter in richtung
mehr wie will nehmen zu wir könnten
schon längst 40 teams zum glück hat
scheiße hier feststellen
ich versuche jetzt mal das klavier zu
verkehrs htpc
ich habe das gerade an professor steckt
ja antworte man in der nähe buchstadt
drauf wie wollte valentin von limonaden
magneto und taub
da ford alter ist das treibsand
slater
gelaufen
klassenleiter aber quadfahrer horchen
auge auf
bisher haben wir in croxall unten
radford gefangen in diesem video fangen
das nicht gelohnt hat und das ist
eigentlich too paradox aber der war
gerade ausgesagt oder mein handy bin ich
jetzt gerade mehr angekommen ganz aus
dem stegreif wasserkante wir versuchen
nach vorne zu fangen es ist sehr
schwierig mit dem ball los
ich hab angefangen
damit haben jetzt das dritte pokémon
heute gefangen b 454 sie eigentlich wie
oft auf meinem level markt investiert
jeden tag 20 euro in die sie gesagt ich
habe noch nie diese glücks alltag
angewandt also ich wollte die tage
einfach mal mit glück so herumlaufen
alles entwickelt weil ich irgendwie 4
milliarden tauglich
er wird in dem video heute drei oder
vier pokémon gefangen glaube ich aber es
ist viel zu schön dass ich muss mal kurz
ich dachte halt einfach eine witzige
idee mit dem handy ins bett zu gehen und
zu gucken ob man da irgendwas findet so
krasse pokemon oder so wollte vielleicht
mal ein video den ich mir so einen speed
boot kaufen so ein kleines damen handy
draufpackt und versuche damit eier
auszubrüten die figuren oder kompressor
wenn ihr mal ernsteres pokémon go video
haben wollt also sowas von wegen seine
pokemon machen wir hier die damit im
ernst und in die kommentare irgendwann
für die sagen was erreichen kann ich mir
richtig traurig dass jetzt mit 22
minuten rauch nur drei punkten gefangen
habe
n tv medion chat